Les ordinateurs sont devenus absolument incroyables.
On se promène avec des super-ordinateurs dans notre poche.
C'est formidable, n'est-ce pas ?
Il est donc décevant de constater
que notre façon d'utiliser les ordinateurs et d'interagir avec eux
n'a pas vraiment changé au cours des 50 dernières années.
Toujours avec une souris et des claviers. En cliquant sur des écrans, des boutons.
C'est pareil pour les téléphones mobiles.
On utilise seulement nos doigts à la place d'une souris.
Alors c'est ça ?
Est-ce à ça que ressemble l'avenir ?
Nous serions coincés derrière des écrans
sans voir le monde autour de nous ?
Ce n'est pas l'avenir que j'imagine, ni qui m'attire.
Je me suis toujours intéressé aux objets,
les objets physiques de tous les jours, comme ceux sur cette table,
auxquels cette famille ne fait pas attention.
Ils sont notre histoire et disent qui nous sommes.
Ils en disent long sur nous.
Laissez-moi vous donner un exemple.
Voici des photos d'objets touchés par une personne en une journée.
Que pouvez-vous dire de lui ?
Il aime sa moto, n'est-ce pas ?
C'est le plus grand objet sur la photo.
Que pouvez-vous dire de cette fille ?
Elle passe tout son temps à la plage.
Elle a une planche de surf.
Elle habite au bord de la mer.
Que pouvez-vous dire de ce type ?
C'est un chef cuisinier.
Regardez tous les ingrédients qu'il a touchés pendant sa journée,
en préparant à manger.
Son ordinateur n'est qu'une partie infime de sa vie,
cet objet triste dans le coin.
Donc, si nous utilisons des objets tout le temps,
et qu'ils occupent une grande part de notre vie,
peuvent-ils devenir notre moyen d'agir dans notre vie numérique ?
Le monde peut-il devenir votre interface ?
C'était mon idée.
J'y travaille depuis 20 ans.
Mon idée est que, pour vivre notre vie numérique,
nous n'ayons plus besoin d'écrans, de claviers ni de souris.
Nous pourrions vivre notre vie numérique
seulement à travers ce que nous utilisons au quotidien.
Et pour concrétiser cette idée, je dois résoudre trois grands défis.
Laissez-moi vous en parler.
Le premier, évidemment : est-ce possible ?
Comment pouvez-vous transformer un objet de votre quotidien
en interface informatique ?
J'ai été inspiré par « L'Éthique des hackers »
que j'ai lu adolescent,
et l'une des idées principales de ce livre,
c'est de pouvoir changer le sens des objets
en inventant de nouvelles technologies, puis en piratant les objets
et en les modifiant.
J'ai donc réfléchi au type de technologie que je pourrais inventer
pour pirater des objets que nous utilisons tous les jours
et les rendre interactifs.
En y travaillant, j'ai inventé ce capteur
qui injecte de la tension électrique dans un objet
et le transforme en interface haptique.
Cette poignée, inchangée, peut donc devenir un capteur de mouvement.
Elle comprend et ressent la façon dont on la touche.
Elle reconnaît la façon dont je la saisis.
Cette poignée est inchangée.
Elle n'a rien de spécial.
Tout objet peut devenir interactif.
Qu'en est-il des plantes ?
Les plantes sont intéressantes car
elles sentent quand on les touche.
Ainsi, la barre se déplace horizontalement sur l'image.
Elle peut se transformer en interface musicale.
(Tonalités musicales)
Il y a aussi des applications pratiques :
un calendrier relié à une plante pour ceux qui sont obnubilés par le côté pratique.
(Rires)
Nous pouvons donner une personnalité aux objets.
(Notes basses changeant de hauteur)
Dans cet exemple en particulier,
l'orchidée peut communiquer avec vous
grâce à des images et des sons.
Elle n'aime pas qu'on la touche et crée donc ces images électriques
qui pestent contre vous.
Cette plante, par exemple,
est plus robuste, c'est une plante serpent,
et elle aime jouer. Elle interagit avec vous.
Chaque objet peut donc être différent
et chaque objet peut représenter ce qu'il ressent.
Tout peut être piraté, tout y compris votre corps.
Dans cet exemple, nous piratons votre corps
afin que vous puissiez mesurer comment se plient vos mains
puis utiliser vos gestes pour contrôler autre chose.
Alors si vous ne voulez pas écouter une musique mille fois,
vous pouvez simplement couvrir vos oreilles pour l'éteindre.
Tout peut donc être piraté et la recherche est importante,
mais notre deuxième défi est
comment passer de la R&D et des prototypes à des produits réels ?
Comment produire de vrais objets, qui peuvent aussi être des interfaces ?
Et on peut se demander qui le ferait ?
La Silicon Valley ?
En passant par Shenzhen ?
Le défi réside dans le fait que le monde des objets est immense.
Chaque année, le secteur textile produit 150 milliards de vêtements.
En comparaison, on ne fabrique que 1,4 milliard de téléphones.
Le monde des objets est bien plus grand que celui de la technologie.
La technologie ne peut pas changer le monde des choses.
A la place, il faut créer une technologie qui change les fabricants d'objets,
les gens qui font vos chaises, vos vêtements et le reste,
en fabricants d'objets intelligents,
qui leur permette d'en créer.
Pour tester cette idée, nous avons eu une idée très simple et lancé un défi :
un tailleur peut-il fabriquer un vêtement connecté ?
Nous ne voulions pas choisir un tailleur
pour le transformer en ingénieur électricien.
On veut toujours qu'il soit un tailleur.
Ce que nous voulions faire, c'est créer une technologie
qui ressemble, ressent et agit comme une matière brute utilisée par le tailleur
pour confectionner ses vêtements.
Par exemple, pour un tailleur, un écran tactile ressemblerait à ceci.
Fait en tissu, on peut le couper avec des ciseaux et le coudre.
En même temps, il doit conserver ses qualités.
Pour faire de cet écran tactile un tissu,
il faut une approche très différente des produits électroniques grand public.
Dans notre cas, nous avons dû aller dans les montagnes de Tokyo
dans une petite usine fabriquant depuis des générations des pièces de kimonos.
Nous avons travaillé avec mes collaborateurs
qui n'étaient pas des ingénieurs.
C'était un artisan qui sait comment fabriquer des vêtements,
et une artiste qui sait comment les rendre beaux.
En travaillant avec eux, nous avons créé un des meilleurs fils du monde,
composé de minces alliages métalliques,
enveloppés de fibres de polyester et de coton.
Ces fils ont été fabriqués par les mêmes machines
qui ont produit des fils pour des kimonos depuis des générations.
Nous avons ensuite emmené ces fils à l’usine,
qui fabrique des vêtements.
Nous avons tissé nos textiles intelligents avec des machines ordinaires,
des couleurs et des matériaux variés
et nous les avons donnés à un tailleur
de Savile Row à Londres.
Les tailleurs sont traditionalistes, surtout à Savile Row.
Ils n'utilisent pas d'ordinateur.
Ils n'utilisent pas de machines.
Ils utilisent leurs mains et coupent.
Ils ajustent leur produit sur le corps humain,
pas sur des avatars 3D.
La technologie ne fait pas partie de leur vocabulaire,
mais ils sont modernes.
Ils savent comment utiliser la technologie.
Si la technologie peut prendre la forme
d'un bouton, d'un textile ou de quelque chose qu'ils peuvent utiliser,
alors ils peuvent complètement en faire un vêtement connecté,
un vêtement pouvant passer un appel téléphonique.
(Sonnerie de téléphone)
Nous avons prouvé qu'il est possible de fabriquer un vêtement connecté,
réalisé par un tailleur et non par une entreprise d'électronique.
Nous avons travaillé et collaboré avec Levi's,
notre partenaire et voisin,
pour créer un véritable produit.
Et ce produit, c'est le blouson que je porte en ce moment.
Vous pouvez l'acheter. Il est en vente.
Il a été fabriqué dans les mêmes usines que tous les produits de Levi's.
Vous avez remarqué
que je dirige ma présentation depuis la manche de mon blouson.
Je frôle la manche vers le bas, ça avance. Dans l'autre sens, ça recule.
Et bien sûr, je peux faire plus de choses.
Pas seulement diriger une présentation.
Je peux aussi maîtriser ma navigation, ma musique,
mais surtout ça reste un blouson, un objet,
qui me donne une belle apparence.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Et c'est le plus important.
(Rires)
On a donc prouvé qu'on peut transformer les objets en interfaces.
On a prouvé que ces objets peuvent être créés par des fabricants
et non par des entreprises technologiques.
J'ai un super look. Avons-nous terminé ?
(Rires)
Pas encore.
Le troisième défi :
comment changer d'échelle ?
Comment passer d'un produit à beaucoup de produits ?
C'est ce sur quoi nous travaillons actuellement.
Laissez-moi vous expliquer comment nous allons faire.
Tout d'abord, je veux être clair :
je ne parle pas d'Internet des objets.
Je ne parle pas de créer un autre gadget
dont vous vous lassez, que vous jetez au fond de votre tiroir
et que vous oubliez.
Je parle du principe fondamental et majeur qui guide mon travail :
« La technologie doit améliorer les objets existants. »
Elle les améliore en les connectant à notre vie numérique
et elle ajoute des nouvelles fonctionnalités utiles,
tout en gardant le même but initial,
sans le changer.
Le blouson que je porte peut contrôler mon téléphone portable et ma présentation,
mais il reste un blouson.
Cela signifie qu'une fois qu'on rend les objets connectés et interactifs,
tous les objets auront leurs propres actionneurs, écrans et capteurs,
spécifiques pour chacun d'eux.
Une paire de chaussures de course n'a pas besoin de capteur tactile.
Pourquoi en aurait-elle ?
Si elle contenait un capteur,
il mesurerait la performance à la course
ou l'impact sur le genou,
sans affecter les qualités de ces chaussures.
Les fabricants d'objets devront se mettre à penser
au type de fonctionnalités digitales qu'ils ont à offrir à leurs consommateurs.
Ils devront devenir des fournisseurs de services,
ou bien ils risquent de disparaître.
Nous devrons fournir et créer un écosystème de services,
comme celui des téléphones mobiles,
avec des applications, des services et tout le reste.
Et parfois, vous passez encore un appel téléphonique.
Pour rendre viable cet écosystème, il faut éviter la fragmentation.
Éviter d'avoir des interfaces différentes pour des gens et des objets différents.
Il faut créer une expérience utilisateur uniforme
et, c'est pourquoi, nous devons créer une plateforme informatique unique
qui alimente tous ces objets.
Comment sera cette plateforme ?
A mon avis, la réponse va de soi :
elle sera basée sur l'informatique en nuage.
Il est bien sûr impossible de connecter les objets directement au nuage.
Il faut donc créer de petits appareils qui peuvent être branchés à tous les objets
et les connecter au nuage
pour libérer leur potentiel et ajouter de nouvelles fonctionnalités.
Je vous montre, pour la première fois, le vrai appareil qui a été construit.
Nous le montrons pour la première fois.
Voici à quoi il ressemble :
c'est un petit appareil,
qui sera connecté aux objets que l'on veut rendre intelligents,
connectés et interactifs.
Comment fonctionne-t-il ?
A l'arrière, vous avez des électrodes.
Quand vous les branchez à différents objets,
comme ici,
l'appareil va reconnaître où vous les branchez,
puis se reconfigure pour activer des fonctionnalités spécifiques
à cet objet en particulier.
On aimerait donner cet appareil à des fabricants,
aux gens qui fabriquent vos vêtements, vos meubles,
afin qu'ils l'utilisent comme ils le font avec un bouton ou une fermeture éclair.
Et ce qu'ils vont en faire, c'est à eux d'en décider.
On ne veut pas leur imposer des usages.
On aimerait laisser les gens qui fabriquent ces objets –
les artistes, les designers, les marques et les artisans –
imaginer et créer un monde nouveau
où les objets sont connectés
à toutes ces nouvelles fonctionnalités numériques géniales.
Nul besoin de clavier, de souris ni d'écran pour interagir avec un ordinateur.
Je travaille sur cette idée depuis 20 ans
et, aujourd'hui, elle prend forme.
Et en même temps, je me rends compte
que j'ai toujours cru travailler sur des interfaces informatiques.
Je me suis toujours vu comme un designer d'interactions,
mais je me rends compte que je ne construis pas d'interfaces.
Ce que j'ai compris, c'est que mon équipe et moi,
nous construisons un nouveau type d'ordinateur,
un ordinateur ambiant.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)